What are your thoughts on high dose hydrogen magnesium and bicarbonate therapy?
So if you're doing this person asks this question of me in a phone consultation we also had
and he's talking about those machines that use hydrogen that you're breathing in that hydrogen
and it's magnesium in a bicarbonate. I think those machines are great. The hydrogen machines that are
out there are really good years ago. I remember when they first came out, I was at a seminar when they
were introducing them. It was an A4M seminar. Oh gosh, about eight years ago. I can't remember
who was track of time. I almost pulled the trigger and bought one but that was when COVID was starting
and we were seeing less people in the office. So I thought, well, I don't know who I would use this
on and I think using it just for a couple of days of a person that's coming in from Kentucky or something
like that is not going to help at all. So I didn't do it. At that time, they were quite expensive.
I think he mentioned that they came down greatly in cost. So I do think they're good machines
and I think they're beneficial. Now the only part of this question that I might take dispute is
in stand-up chemo. I wouldn't necessarily say that anything takes the place of something else.
So chemo therapy is very different than doing the high dose hydrogen and maybe they're selling it
that way. Do it this instead of chemo. And maybe there's probably right companies that are selling
rites. Do this instead of chemo. And just be careful with that terminology. I don't know if that
is that what you meant by that. But instead of doing chemo, can I try this first? I would say
absolutely. But instead, you know, if like, oh, you're not going to tell you're a college or so,
I'm not going to do chemo. I'm going to do this instead. They probably laugh at you. So you're not,
chemo is a very caustic substance. It can have a lot of benefits because it could kill cancer.
But it can have a lot of side effects where this is going to give you new side effects. But it's
probably not going to give you equal and quick benefit. So it's combination of things that you're doing
that's going to help with your cancer. I think this is one thing that would be just great to add
to your protocol. So I think there we go.